foreign
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the meeting of the audit and governance
committee on Tuesday the 22nd 26th of
September
the first item on the agenda apologies
for absence
from councilor Brenton okay thank you
Kirsty
um
right I just like to welcome Noah
to the meeting
who's our graduate trainee
and move on to item number two
confirmation of the minutes the meeting
held on the 18th of July
I'll just go through pages very quickly
three
four
five
and six
as there are no
um
points raised I will move that they are
true representation the minutes do I
have a second to please
thank you Stephen
all those in favor
against
and abstentions
one extension thank you
item three Declarations of Interest
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item describe the nature of
their interest when the item is
considered
item number four agreements of agenda
items part one and two we do have a part
two this afternoon so I propose from the
chair that we will go into part
all in favor
unanimous
urgent matters brought forward by the
chair I don't have any items
so item number six update regarding the
2021 and
22 and 2022 23 accounts Pages seven and
eight
and to receive an update regarding those
accounts
so
Gordon over to you 122 and 22 23
accounts
um without wishing to fully go into the
technical accounting issues there has
been a debate over the the need to to
restate the 2122 accounts due to the the
fact that the the audit haven't been
completed at the time that the triennial
valuation of the pension fund was
complete
um this was effectively a post balance
sheet event
um so even though there was a view
previously to not restate the accounts
after further discussions with with with
the Auditors we did instead choose to
restate the accounts
um to allow the issue to move on so so
the report just explains some of this
background it explains the reasons why
we didn't previously want to restate the
accounts and some of the further
Communications that have come along
since and what some of the consequences
would be to the authority if we weren't
to to make these restatements in terms
of reputational damage potentially with
having um qualified audit opinions
and of course this impacts on two
Financial years because of course if we
didn't restate the 2122 balances then
that would meant that the opening
balances for 22.23 would also be
perceived to be materially inaccurate
so the the draft accounts that will be
signed off at the end of the meeting
which are based upon the restated
position for the um the triennial
evaluations
thank you very much Gordon
item number seven update to the
2021-22 audit finding reports from Grant
Thornton
so we're receiving
an update from you thank you Andrew
thank you chair
um so
is it okay if I start with the award
it's fine
um so
on in terms of 2122
um
I probably won't go into much detail
there Gordon set out quite nicely what
the the point was so since since the
previous committee
um the the authority restated the
accounts we've checked those accounts
we've got the uh the pension fund
Auditors letter of assurance over the
the changes to those assumptions and and
the the data that sits behind it so
therefore that that work is all is all
concluded uh that that led to a it was
an 11.8 million pound reduction in the
liability on the balance sheet that the
adjustment that was made
um and a small a small adjustment on the
on the cies
um there's
so in terms of 21 22 we're in a position
there once we've got the signs we've
reapproved accounts the letter of
representation signed and the the
resigned annual governance statement
we're looking to sign that opinion the
Audi report issue that tomorrow so that
will be 21.22 done
um
in terms of 22. so on value for money
we've got the value for money work for
21 22 and 22.23 they are both still
outstanding at this point we've got a
we've got a member of our local
government advisory team in doing that
work at the moment started visual
planning the and the time scales for
that is to get that work completed by
the end of December so therefore sign
off in January ahead of then the
Handover to to Bishop Fleming with 22 23
21-22 all finished so we
we're catching up and hopefully just in
time to hand over to to Bishop Fleming
so we can make that process as smooth as
possible in that transition
in terms of 22 23
I have set out within the within the
report so Pages Pages 15
onwards and it's just a bit of progress
about you know in terms of the the risks
that we set out in our audit plan back
at the it was the the March March
committee we issued our aortic plan for
22. this the the only issue the only
matter that we found today that needs to
brought to your attention is on the um
is on the group
um and that is there was just a an
amendment made to the group cies where
the net position had been included but
not the gross so in terms of the bottom
line it makes no difference but the two
figures going in were slightly and
that's set out on page 20 of the report
so that's an update is to kind of where
we actually where we are in terms of the
actual audit findings report
which starts on page 26.
again I wasn't going to go into a great
deal of detail there because effectively
all this does is close everything off so
the last one that came was back in
October 22 and at that point it said
there were a number of areas of work
outstanding so this updates it as an
audit adjustment because that wasn't
something it wasn't an error in the
accounts as such it was just something
that would come more more information
had come to light which which gave
information about stuff that was
available prior to the balance sheet
date
the only other
the only other point that I just need to
bring to members attention
is in terms of the property plant and
Equipment note was changed as part of
our closing procedures where we noted
that the
depreciation after re-evaluation hadn't
been cleared out and that's a
requirement of the code for that to be
done again has no impact on the bottom
line because the netbook values that
were in the accounts and went into the
balance sheet were correct it was just
that it the way it was showing with the
gross and net on the Node wasn't wasn't
in line with the code
that's all I was going to say chair in
terms of
where we are in terms of and and sort of
the way forward I'm happy to take any
questions on on any of that
if members have got any
thank you the only point I would make
where you've given us the dates that
you're projecting things to be signed
off and so forth if there's any variance
could you keep us informed please yeah
okay thank you
members do you have any questions to ask
it's all straightforward
okay
thank you very much Andrew
right we'll now move on to
item number eight
the update on Devon audit partnership
what it's completed so over to the audit
partnership manager
yeah thank you thank you chair so pull
me the last from download it part chip
so
um this is our standard update on our
Assurance
awareness in essence we're reporting on
free audits this time so just to briefly
um go free through each of them so waste
and recycling where we provided a
reasonable Assurance so
um I suppose our viewers about future
collection targets can be met but the
waste service is is working close to uh
capacity and the challenges in in
maintaining staff getting the drivers
and so on and and also of course as you
you know sort of issues on on placement
of a new operations center across across
the the river which is important to
centralize operations and and enable the
targets to be met that that said
um we thought it was a good focus on on
delivering a good good service and
management are very seemed very
competent and skilled and knowledgeable
so we're quite impressed in that regard
so social media and comms again so that
was a reasonable Assurance
um accounts as uses a wide variety of
communication mess
Forum to sort of communicate with with
the public
there was good control from the central
team who in essence sort of vet most of
the comms going out from the from the
council to ensure that you know it's
appropriate and so on
uh we did note that social media policy
needs needs to be reviewed and updated
because it's um some some years since
since that was done and also has a good
process to receive and review the
comments and complaints that it receives
and and did we noted the register of
interest is completed and holds details
of of interest of counselors and also
officers a link on the public website
allows members of public to see the
declared sort of
decorations from members and there are
relevant annual checks of conflicts of
interest particularly for senior
officers and a code of conduct for
obviously held separate ones for for
members and and officers
um just and then a couple of other
things to note on that paper so
um so we're currently leading activity
to recruit some independent members to
audit committees um audit committees
have independent members so these are
the members these are individuals who
have a lot of experience in in finance
and local government and so on
um so we're we're looking to lead some
work for our partners I think torrage
has yet to decide if they want to take
part in that but obviously
um
so so we'll we'll wait and see if they
if they do decide but I think um
previous order committees I think
members have highlighted that they may
not have a you know the necessary
factual awareness and skills that that
um for foreign audit committee so that
would help fill that Gap
um and then
um finally on that paper so we're
holding committees
and and officers are invited to to the
event so um and we can send out a flyer
and then
um the second document in in in in pack
is our audit chartering strategy
which
um we're sort of presenting it to you
for approval
um it's so calm of our stands that we
provide these documents due to
um to approve in essence they detail the
rather than responsibilities of internal
debt senior officers and and members of
the committee and so on so clarifying
all those responsibilities
um and quite a long document but so I'll
I'll stop there and ask
um if there's any any questions on those
um on those papers
any questions committee Lauren
um thank you very much I just wanted to
say that I fully support the idea of um
independent members being brought on to
the committee to give us some additional
expertise this was mentioned and I hope
that that is supported by the council so
hopefully that will that will move ahead
and thank you for the invite to the
um
members to the event I don't think I'll
be able to make it myself unfortunately
but I think it's a really good thing for
us to try to
um
have as much training and experience and
discussions about this kind of thing as
humanly possible and so that'll be a
really good thing and then secondly
um
the the actions that you've highlighted
so much of that area
um and then you know does that does
someone need to bring that to an agenda
or is that something that they will
decide on moving forward what happens to
those actions now
so
um that's not a recommendation per se in
our report I think we've highlighted and
we've seen for instance the mid Devon
have have moved uh sort of um to a
similar operation and this year recently
and seeing increase in recycling rates
and obviously reduction in actual waste
and so on and it's proving beneficial to
them so I think in report we're
highlighting it as as
as something to for the council to look
at but I think it's probably not
feasible at the moment until you move to
your single operations center and and
sort of sort those aspects out than than
I think it's a long longer term
goal myself
right if I could just
um pick up on one of those issues on
Western Recycling you see that we're
fairly near capacity at the moment now
we're building out houses in
um so um so you've currently got four
sites and you're obviously going down to
to one
um and
um
I I think we need to I need to refer to
offices in terms of that that question
or or the probably waste and recycling
manager would need to come and talk
about I mean there's so many many
different aspects you've got the staff
you've got the drivers and and you've
got vehicles and of course we know that
locally the the roads are deteriorating
and and that's having impact on the the
vehicles and their sort of Maintenance
requirements and so on
um so um
I suppose
you could say if if they got increased
amounts of
recycling they might not be able to to
merge it
yeah I was I was just looking for a sort
of independent challenge you know
because obviously our officers
you know Richard Hayes does an excellent
job
but you're there to just sort of give
them
another pair of eyes on it to scrutinize
where you think the position is and
that's why I asked the question just as
a challenge
thank you
um social media policy he said
he could do with updating is there any
specific area where
you think we need to look at it or is it
just
to refresh the dates should I put it
like that is there anything that we
really need to look at well I think we
sort of thought about accessibility and
I think there's always a tendency to
think that you can sort of
um
um the social media platforms
that there is also I suppose a risk of
having too many channels
um and and perhaps focusing on on a
smaller number but
um I think that those of us have a
couple of areas to consider
but but personally I mean I received for
um the council sort of comms and so on I
think you issue quite a lot of of stuff
interesting stuff and so on so there's
almost a risk of being overloaded with
stuff that is sent out
um also I mean I do highlight things
like your annual reports which again two
other councils you I think is is a
really good mechanism and I assume that
members appreciate that as a because
that is uncommon across the districts
for them to for Council to have an
annual report saying well this is all
the stuff that we've done and delivered
and so on um which I think as I said is
really beneficial as a as a sort of
brief guide for members of public to see
so um
you're doing well in that respect
and then the final point you brought up
was our independent member under the
Redmond review
um it's always a bit challenging because
we don't live in a sort of University
town or have
a great pool of people with accountancy
skills and knowledge of these things to
fill up that
um non-elected member for auditing
governance and
then the last advert didn't prove that
successful did it not at all
so so on that I suppose our thinking is
that
um if we can get a variety of posts and
different order committees that might be
desirable in terms of not just one
position on one audit committee but a
number that'll give it some scale um but
also I suppose reach out to different
individuals that we have contacts with
and and so on but you know we can we can
help with a recruitment campaign and and
and and see if we do get
um in interest generally
um and I think the other point is about
having
um and I know something that I think
torridge needs to discuss but having a
common
rate of allowances for these individuals
which would mean that different councils
not bidding different amounts of money
for for a member for Independence to
come and join and so that's our thinking
that we'll I think the thing is we'll do
up our best
with a nice small pool of of people the
bright house she picked it the thing
well I think what we we're not against
uh doing anything collaborative is just
working through the mechanics how it
fits in with our other independent
members on other committees because we
see Paul mentioned around remuneration
there's also things about voting rights
for those uh independent members so we
just need to make sure we've got
um all the right things in the right
place before we push ahead to them
well thank you for three very excellent
reports Paul and um I look forward to
seeing you buckfast in November okay
thank you very much indeed
right we're now moving on to
um
item number 10.
yep sorry I beg a pardon item number
nine internal audit Charter and strategy
pages 72-91
and back again to you Paul uh yes so I
did uh mention that so as I said this is
our old Charter and strategy it's quite
a long document
um and and sort of details out the roles
of the role of internal audit role of of
officers and the role of members and
parents you know what they are and how
important is to support
um as part of government's framework
so um as I said it's Daniel standard
document we present every year so you're
happy to
take any questions that people have got
on it a lot there's a lot of detail on
there which is also mandated by the
standards our internal audit standards
um but have to take any questions
it's something that we're very familiar
of year on year so
um I'm happy to take it as read
unless anybody has any points to raise
on it
okay we will note that item
item nine and move on to item 10 which
is the outcome of the Ripper inspection
our head of legal and governance
monitoring officer isn't here this
afternoon so Steve I believe you're
saying something in her stead uh yes
thanks chair so apologies you'll have me
to present and the second apology go
into a little bit of detail so Ripper
actually stands for the regulation of
inspec regulation of investigatory
Powers Act
which is around the use on regulation of
covert surveillance for investigations
and the like as you can imagine quite a
highly regulated area because
intruding in people's lives and to
covert surveillance Etc isn't something
you'd all ordinarily expect to happen uh
kind of infringing on individuals rights
um so
um as a Public Authority we are able to
use those powers in certain
circumstances otherwise I guess you'd
expect the thresholds are consider a
large number of processes and procedures
we have to go through before any
authorization is given to any of our
officers uh to undertake any covert
surveillance of any of any nature
um so we've got a lot of forms and
things to fill in before we go there it
has to be authorized by somebody from
senior management team and even then he
has to go through a process of judicial
approval so it's not simply a case of
somebody signing off then an officer
goes out starts uh filming individuals
to doing certain things we've also got
to keep a central record and that's what
this inspection was about it takes place
on a regular basis uh the inspect
inspector from the office of
surveillance Commissioners comes in
expects our policies inspects any
authorizations any surveillance has been
undertaken all the correct procedures
Etc have been followed properly
um happy to say the inspector
reviewed our policy and is happy with
our policy and our procedures and
ultimately believe we've only done one
at one case of recording in the last
three years back in 2020 which was
related and approved in relation to a
Serial fly chipper chair so happy to
take any questions ibrani but we've got
a positive inspection
I'm very happy with your report Steve I
don't have any questions
nope so we'll note that item and thank
you for it
so we move on to item number 11 which is
a forward plan on page 92
I don't have any amendments to it so are
we happy to take it as read
thank you
right so I'm going to move from the
chair
to
move that the public be excluded from
the remainder of exempt information by
virtue of paragraph three of part one
and paragraph 10 of part two of schedule
12a of the Local Government Act
1972. do I have a second there please
thank you Jude all those in favor
unanimous so if we come offline